ja wir müssen jetzt mal ein bisschen
improvisieren wir sind in einem
hinterzimmer in einem hinterzimmer in
einem hotel in abidjan jetzt grade sonst
eine pressekonferenz gegeben hat genau
so genannten kaminzimmer und ich gebe
ihm ein bein stellen können sie da
nämlich rein sprechen
der ist so die anna von bayern ist da
und herr lindner wie schlimm war die
situation dass sie selbst anreisen
mussten und wie schlimm ist es denn wenn
sie selbst jetzt ihr ganzes politisches
gewicht in die waagschale werfen mussten
sie haben indirekt er gestern schon und
dann heute auch mit rücktritt gedroht
wenn nur eine gliederung ihrer partei
mit der ard zusammenarbeitet sie haben
heute mehr als zwei stunden mit wolfgang
emmerich und der fraktion gebraucht und
sie stellen morgen noch die
vertrauensfrage alt als
bundesvorsitzender so der druck muss
erheblich gewesen sein wie schlimm war
es und wie schlimm ist es ihre partei
ist es existenziell haben ganz klar
könnte nicht eine arbeit fortsetzen
neben die in der eigentlichkeit als er
steht völlig ausgeschlossen
und als sichtbar wurde dass in dieser
konstellation es keine sachbezogene
zusammenarbeit mit den anderen parteien
des demokratischen zentrums also
millionen spd grüne hat geben können
völlig klar dass man das beenden muss
mit die lage haben hier beraten
die notwendige harte entscheidung hat
der kämmerer richtern getroffen treffen
müssen wenn man das richtig
interpretiert also sie sprachen gerade
von der forensik der in der entscheidung
und gestern waren nicht dazu bereit
heute morgen im morgenmagazin auch nicht
dann sind sie angereist und haben sie
mehr als zweieinhalb stunden mit ihm da
gesessen und dann ist es irgendwann klar
geworden also so klar scheinen liberalen
gewesen zu sein wo die brandmauer steht
es war eine lageentwicklung natürlich
auch nicht verkennen welche sehr sehr
schwierigen persönlichen politischen ist
auch eine frage des mit menschlichen
umgangs nicht eine selbstkorrektur und
assoziiert
soviel dazu und vielen dank also so
kurzfristig und so holterdiepolter dann
doch noch möglich war
vielen dank christian lindner und damit
erstmal zurückgezogen danke danke
christian lindner natürlich wir wollen
jetzt